then gob
Gilmore Girls fans are so close to
finding out if we'll be seeing any more
of that go down cuz Milo Ventimiglia is
of course headed back to Stars Hollow
for the Netflix revival I got some
exclusive scoop from the star about the
reboot when we caught up over the phone
here's what he said about where jess is
today didn't surprise me since
surprising him le where we pick up with
him and what he's up to and kind of what
he pops into Stars Hollow to accomplish
and I'm not saying therefore you're not
there to do something but he what whoops
learn from his character and was
discovered from his character and was
earned from his character it didn't
surprise me I thought I thought it was
but I was that nice
you know just kicking the ass that that
everybody kind of liked what the bad boy
that he was Milo said he rapped on the
series last week but doesn't think it's
goodbye I've been fortunate enough over
the last 20 years to work with a lot of
great folks that you get there you get
to hang on to in life and relationships
live beyond jobs the jobs you just you
know the experiences they kind of set in
motion for something a lot wrong so
saying goodbye is more like I'll talk to
you soon about the next week of zero